there's been an awakening
something big is coming from the minds
that brought you the screen junkie show
movie fights and honest trailers comes a
new streaming service so massive so
awesome so amazing it will change the
way you see movies and television
forever getting someone hit the lights
screen junkies plus a new network
created entirely for movie fans
featuring shows from the most epic
voices in movies and TV
Nick Mundy and Dan Burrell Jeremy Jones
Chris stuckman Roxy stryer Spencer
Gilbert Andre Meadows how it should have
been dead
Alicia Malone and Andy signor plus
awesome bonus content for the screen
junkies shows you know and love and the
premiere the first ever screen junkies
original scripted series in terns of
feet can we get an intern to fix that
please screen junkies plus premiering
November 17th we're gonna need a bigger
Internet if you want to find out more
about screen junkies plus click on the
link to watch the screen junkies crew
discuss all the details on this week's
movie fights